this is a real passion project for you
like chips you wrote you directed this
movie yes everything and you you had
total control and for a guy who had
total control one of the things that you
made sure you did was have plenty of
nudity that seemed to be something you
wanted was that something you kept
writing that stuff more more oh god I
thought America was demanding it again
if you look at the box office it maybe
they weren't right there's no way to
know there's no way if I had clothes on
we would be the number two comedy in
America if you were you're like that guy
at the party like nude scene nude scene
new to everybody have a nude scene
listen I had asked some females to get
nude in the film and I thought it was
unethical of me to not get nude myself
is how it looked at wait it you were
very good at spinning things now and I'm
a pain he had a nude scene too we'd cut
it out of the movie but he also got nude
I think he just wanted to see more nude
scenes I did I did our rule was every
day of filming we either blew something
up did a sweet motorcycle stunt or we
got naked yeah yeah and that's a good
policy
naked during like directing some of the
scenes yeah that's what I heard is that
your scene that's not even a joke
not even a joke I mean there's a joke
guys the movie didn't do so hot but but
this is
[Applause]
the thing you really were this is true
you were naked for your nude scenes but
then you had to go indirect and some
yelling people he would move his camera
here you wouldn't put a robe on you
would direct in the nude is that this is
what he had so I'm like there's a scene
where I'm like that faceplant into his
junk and and he's naked and he's you
know he's telling me is like you know
what I'm gonna put a sock for you I'm a
first you know sock here yeah and it was
a it was at newts I mean clear you could
see the right through it yeah so I don't
even know why you we're gonna
manufacture this shocking where do you
get a translucent sock look his beef is
with a sock manufacturer not me I didn't
make the sock right right you know that
would be sucked up yeah
one-stop shop for whatever story with
the Merkin then because then he put a
merkin on then I wore a murder win as
just a little courtesy to have a little
stereo a merkin is the wig for the
genital area it simulates pubic hair yes
explaining thing it was I'm an explainer
that's part of the game there's a
fascinating history to it actually it
was made you guys are gonna love it so
it was made popular in the Old West in
brothels because women would get they
would get crabs and they'd have to shave
and then no John wanted to get with a
gal that had clearly had crabs so they
invented these wigs to fool you but not
as interesting as I thought
you